[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute backen wir eine
schneewittchen torte und ich habe auch
ein gast da und zwar ich hatt ich hab
mir vorüber ich habe keine lust diese
torte alleine zu backen ich rufe jetzt
zu meiner rechten die mehr will und wir
haben uns heute auch das erste mal
persönlich getroffen
wir kennen uns durch instagram nach da
sich im jahr bin ich will irgendwann mal
am surfen gewesen und habe dann entdeckt
auf meiner startseite da hattest du so
ein richtig fans das weißt du durch
lässt sich auch zum ersten mal da
hattest du so ein weihnachtsbrief so ein
zucker kriege und somit auch wechseln
dann blendet man hier ein und fand so
geil und dann so kam ich auf dieses jahr
schon fast zwei jahren lernte ich schon
dass wir ein make-up contest das weiß
ich noch ja und hattest du gewonnen
nicht anders erwartet du machst beauty
make up make up expertin ina und ich
verlinke euch die seiten dem die infobox
auf jeden fall mal abstecken und immer
gerne kurz was über dich für mehr bin 22
jahre alt und wie geht die schon gesagt
hat ich liebe make up und ein großer
großer make up navara und ja ich backe
auf meinem gewicht und ja ich bin die
beste küchenhilfe jetzt ich freue mich
auch richtig wir machen heute eine
effiziente ja ich kam darauf habe mir
überlegt was wir zusammenpacken ich bin
nicht gegangen und dachte mir wird auf
so eine porzellan haut und schnell
entwickelt hatte und im anschluss würde
ich mich gerne schminken lassen ja ja
gerne wittchen look passen sie auf
spiegel ein bisschen komplexer so durch
den kopf gehen
natur schön weil okay wir starten jetzt
direkt mit dem rührteig ich wohl die
küchenmaschine unterfangen werden
ich habe hier alle zutaten bereit stehen
hier findet ihr unten in der infobox
ganz nur aufgelistet und ich würde sagen
ich mache jeden tag willst du das
übernehmen geld nicht übernehmen das
heute aber leute ist es wirklich mein
erstes mal mit so natürlich maschine
das kriegt man aber auch kaum ok egal
dann wenn wir jetzt einfach kurz und
alle zimmer warme butter die kannst du
einfach in die luft gehen einfach du
kannst doch hier ja es gab schon so ein
vollprofi hierher funktioniert hätte der
vorfeld so bleiben wir noch zucker dazu
und vanille extrakt und dann schlagen
wir das einfach hier minuten zeit auch
nur drei sondern das richtig schön dick
cremig nach gefühlten perfekt profi du
machst das vorgehen ich glaube ich bin
ich viel krasser als naja als
konkurrenten
die müssen ja einfach runter genau dann
kannst du dir an der seite einfach an
schweiß einfach mittlere stufe
[Musik]
so meine liebe assistent email hat jetzt
gerade doch die eier dazu gegeben kurz
eingerückt und jetzt brauchen wir die
trockenen zutaten also nehmen backpulver
und da würde ich dich bitten dass du das
abwechselnd mit der milch einfach rein
substanzen die maschine hochklappen
das nimmst du das einfach die handeln
kann ich dir das so und jetzt kannst du
einfach so anfang zu drücken nun nicht
alles das was so ab genau es reicht
schon
also der teig ist fast fertig sieht auch
schon sehr sehr schön aus muss ich sagen
und einfach die hälfte in unsere
springform das ist ein 26er springt also
nicht nur die hälfte drauf und dann
schön verstreichen
[Musik]
nein ist noch einmal neu mache ich noch
ein bisschen ein bisschen okay also ist
gut so
das hätte ich das jahrelang du kannst
auch ruhig unsere speziell entwickelte
paletten passen kenne ich ja gar nicht
alle mit dem löffel aber dementsprechend
sind jetzt auch aus holland
also mich bringt ja backen richtig
runter ich entspannter richtig dabei
dieses mit schminken ja ich setze mich
so gerne mein schminktisch und dann kann
ich alle meine gedanken sammeln
beruhigend für mich ist schminken
folglich die morgens keine lust mich zu
schminken
aber ich muss halt damals unreinheiten
das ist ganz normal also für dich halt
nicht backen muss gibt ja sagt er zu tun
hat
nach wieso ganze schläge manchmal werde
ich mich stolz auf dich gut aus und
jetzt machen wir folgendes beim
schneewittchen kuchen gibt es ein
rührteig der besteht einmal aus
helmstedt musste im dunklen teilt mit
wer sich zweimal anrühren wieder voll
nervig besteht eine teig geben wir jetzt
bei kakao und am besten sieben weil er
schon teilweise kempchen hat und noch
ein bisschen billig zum ausgleich
perfekt könnte ziemlich reinigen und
dann einfach nur ich geb dir mal ein
schneebesen
sicher sei aber dass es so entspannt
gerade für mich weil ich wohl auch
leicht schweißperlen noch nicht erreicht
und jetzt gehen wir in die mitte ich
mache so einen teig fans mit dem zehnten
stock einfach drauf verteilt oder
nochmal ganz streichen
man kann mit dem schrauber einfach alles
rausholen
er ist mein job ist nicht so schön dann
haben sie dann müssten wir eigentlich
und habe mit geben ja aber hallo
sondern ich war mal kurz die kirche dass
ich mal eine richtig es sanfter ich habe
anderen kochs die gewachsene okay ist
das glatt genug ja sehr hübschen ich bin
absolut begeistert ist richtig es kann
jetzt hier die kirchen des nap kirschen
aus dem glas ich habe gesagt aufgefangen
bis nicht wegwerfen und die einfach auf
den teig geben soll ich immer alle oder
leben der hand zu bekommen damit dass er
genau und danach drücken wir den ein-
und dann entsteht quasi dieses
weltmeister wie auch bei den summen
aufwenden
ein bisschen studentin
den endzügen und hast du nebenbei ein
bisschen business aufgebaut verdienst du
schon geld also das heißt verdienst du
schon geld damit kannst du davon leben
von dienstag ja also allein von den
youtube einnahmen könnte ich mir mal in
dem wahrscheinlich nicht finanzieren
aber mit instagram und hals youtube
kombiniert finanziere ich mein
komplettes leben aber habe mich damit
komplett finanziell eigentlich
abgesichert ist ja auch kein geheimnis
und dementsprechend kann ich mir auf
meine studenten leben finanzieren am geh
ich auch sehr sehr dankbar hier muss ich
sagen ja wir wollen gerade als studentin
ist man ja ja meistens ein bisschen auch
am ende des monats am limit und viele
studenten gucken japan und da war für
kinder oder hermann gezahlt ich meine es
kommt ja auch nicht war nicht so ein
tutorial wie lange dauert das dass du
das gedreht und geschnitten
also sind youtube tutorial zum beispiel
kann es sein dass ich manchmal zwei drei
stunden dann im luxus und das ist halt
nur das filmen und das video geht dann
wie lange so um die 15 20 minuten kommt
noch das cutten dazu genau das karten
dauert ja auch noch mal so um die
anderthalb zwei stunden kann je nachdem
was den aufwand darum hilft ja da
spricht der profi der hallenser kennt es
sehr sehr schön
und jetzt kannst du dir eigentlich aber
ich geb dir mal eine neue palette von
hinten eine rückkehr nicht einmal so ein
bisschen eindrücken dann packen wir das
auch ich hab den ofen vor gehalt auf 180
grad ober und unterhitze und dann packen
wir den boden für ungefähr 26 bis 28
minuten war es drückt sich auch von
alleine ein bei der hitze gleich und das
backen oder das erst mal
also werden wir den boden abkühlt macht
mehr wir hier die creme und zwar waren
wir davon fünf zutaten frisch käse sahne
butter zucker vanille extra und lasse
mir später noch seine fest einen
riesenjob du weißt du wie es geht oder
ok ja soll ich jetzt kommen sie sehe ich
die chance geben rest aus wir werden uns
meine frage gestellt wenn du ein küchen
produkt welches wärst du dort nicht was
richtig praktisches sein am besten so
kompakt wie möglich das ist ein
interessanter bewerbungs frage auch wenn
die antwort sagt alles über die
ausländischen produkte
ich glaube im wasserkocher ich hätte
jetzt alles erwartet maschine oder
irgendwelche teile wasser kochen braucht
man immer immer gebraucht mich einfach
immer okay ist mein moment sehr schnell
oberkochen ich habe mal gesagt intensive
welchen zauber weil ich aus allem den
rest raushole antwort so gefeiert und
seitdem müssen uns mal kaputt lachen das
ist drin nehmen jetzt einfach seine
puderzucker dann fangen langsam an zu
holen und dann immer schneller
[Musik]
also das ist jetzt die fertige creme der
mir zu vorschnell zusammengerührt und
wird es mal probiert vielleicht fehlt ja
noch ein bisschen zucker die folgen
perfekt muss auch nichts aussagen die
auch so genau richtig wir hatten ja
letztens maulwurf kuchen gemacht hast
das video dazu gesehen
der herr soundso fischaugen links
vergangen ist dass wir uns auch wieder
nicht habe man sogar sagen beim
aufkochen max ja so ein trauma davon ich
habe es geliebt ja wir haben mal im
supermarkt so eine banane eis gekauft
und es konnte man so schön hätte das
okay und wenn man es gegessen die ganze
familie hatte einfach nicht vorstellen
ich will jetzt hier und da reden wir
nochmal großkuchen gemacht und banana
übernahmen dann dass ihnen nicht gut
unter dem kann ich noch mal brauchen
kann ich auch hier kann ich voll
nachvollziehen
das haben wir mal mit einem veganen work
party den wir fertig gekauft haben
gehabt weil sagen willst eklige sachen
besprechen ich glaube über nicht oder es
ist gut wir machen jetzt einfach weiter
grund ich bin manchmal kommen wir gucken
welche tortenplatte reaktion benutzen
marchant ort sondern die roten ihn ja
passt die rolle der bus ist ja auch
weiter geht's also der boden ist
abgekühlt eigentlich kann man die torte
jetzt direkt zusammenstellen heftig wie
schnell das jetzt auch gegen ja das ging
nicht
gibt es einen tortenring darum damit es
später auch schön bist kannst du die
creme einfüllen und glatt streichen ist
voll einfach zu machen wollen wie sie
auch für anfänger geeignet aber ich sehe
ich gar nicht jetzt anfänger du legst du
performance aber jetzt frauen haben
einfach drauf tun bleibt streichen
es muss schon schön aussehen genau wen
genau geteilt
klickt einfach alles im takt
wir liegen damit kann es ein richtig
schönes streichen ich sagte ich bin
lieber einen teig schaber und kein
wasser kochen ist der mit die creme
diese durch die creme bleibt verstrichen
sein nächsten reingefallen ich könnte
mir später noch einfach so eine lücke
auf die torte da machen jetzt folgendes
wir klauen einfach was von der
problemlose 12 tupfer jetzt noch mal
schön glatt streichen
mit dem löffel geht's nicht so gut leute
hatte ich geb dir ich geb dir was da so
genial hier zu schnell
[Musik]
wer den übrig gebliebenen kirschsaft
einfach wird ein bisschen speisestärke
aufkochen lassen und zehn minuten
abziehen lassen genau und jetzt stehen
wir hier unseren bus abkühlen lassen ist
aber noch lauwarm ist schlimm aber ich
wollte es nicht ganz heiß auf die sahne
geben hans klok das so jetzt machen wir
folgendes ich gebe das vorsichtig mit
einem löffel drüber und dann kannst du
das partei verteilt das kann ich gut
gemacht haben wie hübsch habe bevor ich
war das echt wunderschön blutroten total
und so schwingt du nicht gleich ja jetzt
habe das so einfach leute und das ist
schwierig
nein jetzt nur kurz fest bergen zehn
minuten oder so und dann nehmen wir uns
unseren spritzbeutel dann kannst du
diese häufchen dann ist das rezept auch
schon also dann kann ich freue mich dass
es ja auch ich mich also während der
willen der bosse abkühlen habe ich mir
jetzt einfach überlegt du stinkst mich
jetzt nicht genau
schneewittchen ins bei welt darf also
jetzt nicht klappt ist trotzdem jacky
ickx gesicht stehen hier und ich war ein
kind hier neben ihre videos kraft
geschminkt aber jetzt nicht so ungewohnt
wirken auch für die zuschauer
ich verwandle ich schreibe jetzt so ein
bisschen lidschatten auf nicht viel
damit man so ein bisschen in die damit
abdecken damit auch nachher zum flush
passt gab schon mal den frau fall dass
du geschminkt wurde ist und sich nicht
mehr wiedererkannt haus und dachte so
ein fall tatsächlich ja da wurde ich da
wurde ich geschminkt nichts aber nicht
sagen wo das war nicht keine verletzten
aber da wurde ich geschwiegen und dann
hatte ich damals hatte ein paar
unreinheiten zu dem zeitpunkt
stressbedingt die unreinheiten hat man
nach dem schminken mehr gesehen als
umgeschrieben
das passiert sehr schnell wenn man so
viel drauf kreis hat sozusagen wenn dann
sieht man aus wie so ein - 1
weniger ist mehr sachsen ja auf jeden
fall
und ich finde man braucht sich auch
nicht unwohl mit marken zählen weil
jeder also niemand hat ihn vorzuladen
hand ja mit make-up nicht man sieht dass
zwei mal ein youtube videos ist sie ganz
so richtig glatter haut haben was viele
vergessen dass es später so haben wir
eben auch noch mal erklärt das ist so
ist gibt du vollkommen recht auf
instagram in den stories
heute lernt ständig fehlt da und keiner
zeigt sich mehr mit der normalen kamera
vielleicht sollten wir das mal ein
führen dass man einfach grundsätzlich
weniger filter bonus ja es gibt ja auch
voll oft locker die jetzt so eine
challenge taten sind noch filtert er ist
cool cool die dann auch keine stadt homs
eltern verwenden in ihren stories weil
die sind ja auch manchmal sehr sehr
crazy dann hat man plötzlich dickere
lippen nase und dann geht auch einmal
jeder gleich aus also ich habe jetzt
wirklich nur ganz wenig habe gezaubert
auf dieses lied ich lasse mich einfach
mal überrascht dennoch
zwischendurch erzählt ihren eyeliner ich
finde schneewittchen mit einem
schneewittchen denke ich immer noch
einer wir denken hatte ich hatte vor der
ersten welle wo jeder zu hause
und ich hatte dann irgendwann ist man
alleine ausgegangen ich wollte mich
unnötig rau ist ja jeder dass panik zu
hause geblieben und dann habe ich plan b
habe ich einfach so einen schwarzen
lidschatten genommen und seitdem mache
ich das seit über einem halben jahr mag
ich viel mehr geschaffen als einer in
damit nämlich gespannt wieder
tatsächlich aus dass wir auch in der
korona zeit angeführt ich habe jetzt zum
beispiel auch lidschatten in meinen
augen ist richtig zoff tauge habe ich so
strenger kanal doch besser üben ja das
stimmt der chor der allerdings schon
fertig auf der einen seite ja aber so
will eigentlich fertig machen augen zu
wir haben einander gezogen ich habe es
ganz ungewohntes will klickt hier und
jetzt mache ich weiter mit dem fleisch
also wenn ich ein schneewittchen denke
dann denke ich immer so ein rote wangen
ja genau und ich verwende jetzt hier
live band marktcheck krebs und das trage
ich so großzügig auf da die kamera
sowieso alles schlucken
da habe ich gleich meine frage an was
muss ich beachten wenn man zum beispiel
eine lücke hat in den augenbrauen oder
wie wie stellt man am besten sein
das ist so wichtig sinn gesehen also bei
lücke empfehle ich immer geld produkte
die er etwas dunkler sind mit dem man
ein bisschen präziser arbeiten kann zum
beispiel auch von formaten oder ein
augenbrauenstift ich bevorzuge
augenbrauenstift mit dem tool das es zu
das ist nicht so deckend genug deshalb
lücke ausfüllt und mit einem
augenbrauenstift präzise reingehen und
dann nach teheran herrchen nachzeichnung
sozusagen 100 ich hatte mal ne zeit lang
dürfen jetzt nicht wieder zugewachsen
ich hätte dann aber auch bruder benutzen
die prävention auch so viel schnee
wir gehören auch ein bisschen nach dem
magen und augenbrauen stifter sind
meistens wasserfest das ist genau
richtig toll schminken aber ich glaube
das reicht bei euch sogar das kann mir
noch die lippen und die lippen sind das
halt wenn ich die rote farbe sehe ja
bestimmt man denn hinweise make-up
videos in die kamera
also meistens kommen die man ist immer
so offenbar lag mit lipstick und den
drei rote haar war es nur so schwierig
dass man so präzise wie möglich auf
tragen aber ich selber gleich einfach
noch bei kiki mit einem sauberen pinsel
ein bisschen concealer aus also ein tipp
an euch geht aber ganz gut
[Gelächter]
du kannst leicht von den lippen daran
handeln der eigentlich schon fertig rote
lippen eyeliner eigentlich was typisch
klasse klassisches eigentlich nicht
existent kommen eigentlich nicht
ich habe mich wie aus dem gesicht
geschnitten
ich habe mich jetzt nicht gesehen ok
ok also alle da ist heftig leider ist
mir schließlich um ungewohnt ich weiß
nicht ob ich so privat tragen also das
ist sehr sehr schön mal diese also
heftig wie so eine leinwand da hab ich
mir oh nimmt so graf zu krass aber es
ist halt stimme dir du ja durch jetzt
auch so bis heute abend dankeschön gerne
gerne wo wir gerade beim thema sind und
haben jetzt das make-up ja fertig
würdest du jetzt noch junges zum
fixieren
darauf hatten ja ich bereue es nicht
mitgenommen aber es gibt noch speziell
settings praise wie zum beispiel der
augen alter von werbung aber nicht
bezahlt der versiegelt komplett das
ganze gesicht man spürt das auch um
anfragen also eine schutzschicht sollen
drauf und das macht das make-up wirklich
unglaublich lange haltbar
jaja spiel was für ihn habe ich vorher
wirklich so verwenden hat angst noch
keine cassens preis gab habe ich habe
auf meinem gesicht geschrieben
er ist nicht so gesund gemacht also
nicht einen teuren schwamm und das
setting spürt den schwamm an dann drückt
das so richtig in die haut rein und
arbeitet das produkt so richtig in die
haut rein mit dem die fondation dann hat
das richtig richtig lankas ich bin
schuldig kann richtig viel von dir noch
lernen weil man ist super schade man
holt sicherheit leitungen auch viel in
der drogerie ab und zu können nicht mehr
dann auch mal was aus dem highend
bereich
und dann ist es super schade wenn man
sich mühe gibt und das nicht hält also
ich muss einfach mal noch mal ein paar
videos von dir abchecken genau los ist
zu lernen als kult vielen vielen dank
und gucken was sie tatsächlich dann
können wir jetzt direkt weiter machen
etwas gegessen und hallo es hält immer
noch warum bin ich das schuldig einmal
die worte raus aus dem tortenring dafür
nämlich den bug formel soll ich gehe
hier einmal drumherum damit man sich mit
den bussen nicht auseinanderreißen
der mega schade da musst du ja wir haben
sich gegeben
besonders danach würde ich einfach die
dekoration komplett überlassen
bist du dir sicher ich bin mir zu sehen
wollte ich mache heute vn dumas alles
das geht schon mal richtig toll ich hier
mache ich hatte und deshalb gehört ja da
habe ich hier eigentlich müsste ich ja
bei der hälfte 6
gerade zahner gut 34 50 menschheit 9 wir
tanzen aus der reihe müssen nicht wie
anja ist solange wir sind einfach anders
ich habe aber noch häufig richtig
ja wir das mal gemacht afrika wir essen
jetzt einfach zwei stücken selbst nur
noch sieben
okay wir probiert jetzt einfach mal
direkt und nach details des plans auch
ruhig ehrlich oder so kritisch das werde
ich so schnell den schneid hier direkt
an ja unsere ja da sind folglich schön
stück ich finde es wunderschön macht den
anschnitt gespannt
heftig der anschnitt sie wunder
wunderschön und er sieht man auch
richtig diese wellen ich glaube im
nächsten stück sogar noch besser die
donauwellen sie quasi echt wie so eine
todeswelle richtig gerne creme richtig
ein erguss und die perfekten seine
tupfer ich glaube wir haben das auch
schon mega ungeduldig weil er wusste
ganz so kriegt immer gerade genau
probieren war sehr länger ich hasse dich
erst mal spricht für mich nicht selber
loben wobei du eigentlich die torte
gemacht das rezept kam nur von mir
eigentlich nicht haben tatsächlich
vorfall tagen er mir eben gesagt dass
ich aus einer donauwelle und da weil es
von unserer mutter ja das ist bei mir
also ich finde es immer viel zu fehlen
wenn man so das prinzip davon mag dann
ist das perfekt weil das so ist jetzt
hofft das perfekt auf den punkt gebracht
donauwelle ist auch klassisch dass du
wirklich in die creme ein ganzes paket
butter reingehen und das muss man
wirklich mögen und das ist die perfekte
alle dies halt leichter mögen schmeckt
mir definitiv besser
der teig der ist voll locker und die
krise ist hier gibt nochmal so
frischeren frische gegen höhe und der
krönende abschluss ist er hierher muss
auch nichts zu rufen
aber ja sowieso keinen zucker
reingekommen haben gewalt war ja schon
vorgesehen darunter kirch sagt war
stressig genug und das ist vor
sensationell des handels mal probieren
wie findet ihr meinen laufschritt meine
kommentare die kommentare soll ich ab
jetzt in jedem video und so aussehen
aber da musst du immer vorbei aber doch
immer hinter verbinden also ganz viel
freude beim nachbacken würde
einfach mal sagen dann verabschieden wir
euch aus diesen coolen video wenn euch
das format gefällt dann schreibt man
unbedingt kommentar und checkt auf jeden
fall west instagram seite ab und im
youtube kanal von sich und ich mal ein
bisschen was abgucken antippt ja einfach
also bis zum zander unser quiz ist dann
immer so
bis zum nächsten mal das kitzeln der
kurs ist echt lecker
[Musik]
so leute miteinander
das war nicht überall so